افاد مراسل الجزيره بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اطلقت دفعه صاروخيه من شمالي
قطاع غزه باتجاه بلدات ومواقع اسرائيليه
وكان مراسلنا قد افاد بان سفرات الانذار
دوت في مستوطنه يفا سار في غلاف
غزه معنا من تلابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام نبدا اذا بهذا التطور فيما يتعلق
بدفعه صاروخيه في من شمال قطاع غزه وايضا
سير المعارك عموما بالنظر لما يعلن من
ارقام في الاصابات وال الجرحى من ضباط من
ضباط
وجنود بالفعل هذه الارقام التي يعلنها
الجيش الاسرائيلي تشير بشكل واضح الى ان
العمليات العسكريه تحديدا في المناطق
الجنوبيه ما زالت على زخمها وما زالت في
اوجهها وما زالت تجري وجها لوجه بضراوه
وشراسه وتكبد الجيش الاسرائيلي خسائره في
الارواح بين قتيل وجريح وهذه الارقام ربما
تكون خير دليل على حجم هذه المعارك لا سما
وان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن قتال شرس
وضار وعمليات عسكريه كبرى ما زالت تجري
ومسرحها بالتحديد في مدينه خانيونس وتلك
المناطق المحيطه بها والجيش الاسرائيلي ما
زال يتحدث عن انجازات يحققها على الارض
بحسب بياناته في منطقه خانيونس من حيث
الوصول الى معاقله تابعه لحركه حماس
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك مقار او
مستودعات للاسلحه ومنصات للصواريخ
وبطبيعه الحال الانفاق الهجوميه التي
تحاول القوات الاسرائيليه الوصول اليها و
تفخيخها
وتفجيرها الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان
عملياته في منطقه خانيونس متواصله فيما
تنشر بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه على
نحو غير مؤكد ويبدو ان الرقابه العسكريه
ما زالت تحضره حتى الان لكن هنالك تلميحات
في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث
عن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيقلل من اعداد
جنوده العاملين على الاقل في المناطق
الشماليه في غضون الايام القليله ال
المقبله على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
حقيقه في الاسابيع الاخيره كان خفف من
اعداد جنوده بعد ان سحب الفرقه
36 وسحب ايضا اعدادا كبيره من الجنود من
صفوف الاحتياط من ارض المعركه لكن بقيت
بطبيعه الحال بعض الالويه التي تعمل في
المناطق الشماليه ويبدو ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعمل على تقليل اعداد الجنود
هناك في الايام المقبله ربما في اطار تصور
جديد لاعاده انتشار القوات او اعاده
تموضعها في المناطق الشماليه على وجه
الخصوص على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول بانه انهى عملياته العسكريه الكبرى
هناك وبدا ينفذ اعمالا عسكريه محدوده بناء
على معلومات استخباراتيه بعينها فيما تقوم
فرقه من فرق قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي في
مواصله تقطيع اوصال قطاع غزه الى منطقتين
تفصل المنطقه الشماليه بالمنطقه الجنوبيه
وهذه الفرقه تعمل تحديدا في المنطقه
الوسطى لقطاع غزه تحديدا عند الشارع عش
الذي يمتد من غلاف غزه باتجاه البحر بشكل
عرضي وهدف هذه الفرقه هو تق تطيع اوصال
قطاع غزه الى نصفين والاهم من ذلك هو منع
الفلسطينيين من المناطق الجنوبيه من
العوده الى ما تبقى من منازلهم وديارهم في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال حتى الان يطالب المستوى
السياسي بالوقوف على مستقبل سير العمليات
تحديدا في المناطق الجنوبيه والجيش
الاسرائيلي سال كما يبدو المستوى السياسي
في الايام الماضيه هل سيكون هنالك قرار في
المجلس الحربي او في المجلس الوزاري
المصغر يتطرق الى مساله استمرار او توسيع
العمليه العسكريه في جنوب قطاع غزه الى
مدينه رفح والى محور فيلادلفيا الواقع بين
الاراضي الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
والاراضي المصريه حتى الان لا اجابات عن
هذان الموضوعان ويبدو ان الاداره
الامريكيه تعارض هذا الامر بحسب بعض
التقديرات العسكريه في اسرائيل بالاضافه
الى السلطات المصريه التي ترفض اي عمل
عسكري اسرائيلي بمحاذاه حدودها مع قطاع
غزه لذلك هذه هي مساله عالقه والمساله
الثانيه التي يريد الجيش الاسرائيلي
الوقوف عليها مع المستوى السياسي هي مساله
ما بعد الحرب ومن يتولى المسؤوليه عن
اداره شؤون قطاع غزه على اعتبار ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يلاحظ انه في المناطق التي
يخلي فيها قواته تعود حركه حماس للسيطره
عليها من الناحيه العسكريه ومن الناحيه
المدنيه والسلطوية
الاسرائيلي غير معني كما يقول بابقاء هذا
الفراغ على حاله دون اجابات من تلابيب
مراسل الجزيره لس كرام شكرا جزيله
لك